so I published four studies on our NFL
work
the most common finding is decreased
activity in the front part of their
brain so forethought judgment impulse
control
planning empathy
um decreased activity in both their
temporal lobes memory mood stability
temper control and decreased activity in
their cerebellum in the back bottom part
of their brain and that's sort of the
quality control part of your brain it's
sort of the last check before a thought
gets out of your mouth or a behavior
gets out of your body
and
um and these are like incredibly
um coordinated
athletes you know their reaction times
were just off the charts even seeing me
many years later
um
but the cool thing is when I started my
study
the NFL was an active denial that they
had a problem
so clear like let's not lie about it
playing football is a brain damage it's
sport own it because if you don't admit
you have a problem you can't do anything
to solve the problem but what we
discovered that I'm so excited about is
80 of our players got better when we put
them on a brain rehabilitation program
well how cool is that amazing because
that sound it sounded like to me when I
heard about CTE I was like like the
damage is done you know like that
there's just you know you have CTE
um but that is amazing it's reversible
see a lot of players won't come and get
checked because they're like I don't
want to know I have CPE that is
permanent and irreversible that's the
lore going around our society right
right and I'm like
no and we publish this in a scientific
journal eighty percent of our players
get better I was a consultant on the
movie concussion with Wilson yeah I
watched it of course and I was actually
written into the script Peter lamisman's
the writer and director of concussion
and he he's like you're like the only
one talking about Hope and so I have the
joy of being written into a script and
the pain of being written out because
they decided it was going to be a movie
of David versus Goliath with Dr amalo
Who's A friend of mine against the NFL
and I keep bugging Peter and I'm like
you need to do concussion too you need
to tell people there's hope that if you
do the right things you can be better
obviously the earlier you start
the batter and a lot of sophisticated
players actually have hyperbaric
chambers in their homes yeah so I love
that is hyperbaric chamber something you
think that like generally speaking
should be part of it should be everyone
should be thinking about using it or is
there a certain something some some
symptom or a trigger or maybe a you know
maybe being a former former athlete is
there is there something that you would
say low blood flow
hyperbaric oxygen is really good I
recommend it to almost everybody that I
see on imaging has low blood flow if
you've had a concussion and even now the
and probably when you were racing the
concussion protocol was rest and I'm
like that is just so dumb you know you
have to put the brain in a healing
environment
and that's not rest
um so I think for concussions it's
awesome yeah for people who had Strokes
it's been found to be really helpful
after you've had surgery so a lot of
people don't know the general anesthesia
can be bad for the brain so if we go
back to Bright Minds the t is toxins
and children who have general anesthesia
have a higher incidence of ADHD and
learning problems
older adults who have anesthesia have a
higher incidence of dementia that
anesthesiologists never tell you um
we're going to do general anesthesia and
I'm a lower your IQ points like why does
it reduce blood flow what is it about
anesthesia
you know it's not the short-term
anesthesia like you know they give you
pro football for a dental procedure it's
the general anesthesia for some
vulnerable people it decreases blood
flow significantly
and like I'm a psychiatrist why do I
care about that because if you have low
blood flow you're more likely to get
depressed you're more likely to have
brain fog you're more likely to drop and
lose words I want to clarify concussions
real quick because I feel like for me a
lot of people have asked me
how many concussions have you had and
I'm like
I mean it's got to be a scale I'm like I
don't know I've had like two or three
that I had like symptoms from meaning
that night or yeah it's usually that
like sort of like isolated to the day
but I I definitely had some some effect
but I was like I also hit the wall
probably I don't know
60 70 80 times I don't know I I hit the
wall a lot I raced for 27 years I crash
in go-karts I crashed in race cars so
I'm curious because I think that this is
an applicable question to football or
soccer or anything else where there's
not a symptom but you have an impact to
the head you butt heads when you're
tackling you hit it you you take a
header on a soccer ball whatever it may
be
what is it that actually deems an impact
a concussion well technically it's when
you have when you're symptomatic really
like the question is what does more
damage the big hits or the little hits
okay Joe Lewis actually said it best a
famous heavyweight champion boxer he
said it's not the big hits that cause
dementia it's the thousands of little
hits
and so if you think of Navy SEALs for
example they do thousands of breaching
exercises where they're blowing up
things
and that is a sub-concussive blow and
it's like so what happens in a
concussion well the brain starts to
swell
um blood vessels get ripped so you get
these micro bleeds neurons tear
and
um it's not a good thing right so if you
think of the brain as the consistency of
soft butter tofu custard somewhere
between egg whites and jello doesn't
seem like I should have taken butter on
a 240 mile an hour ride just saying
and your skull is not
smooth inside it has sharp bony ridges
why and so you know God and I have had
this discussion several times it's like
why didn't you put bumper guards over
that sharp bony Ridge that's right next
to the amygdala or in racing they'd be
soft they would be safer barriers like
they used to have walls and you just
crash into it and then they created
safer Bears which was a wall in front of
the wall that had essentially it was
movable it wasn't locked down and it and
it and it compressed into foam for safer
barriers athletes are so important
um and just giving a little forethought
to their health is is so important I
I've had season tickets to the Lakers
for like ever and when Kobe Bryant was
playing with Lamar Odom it came out and
it was 2007. the NBA Championship that
Lamar Odom was eating 80 dollars of
candy a week
and so I wrote an op-ed piece that got
published in the New York in the Los
Angeles Times like why are why do they
not have a nutritionist for somebody
they're paying 14 million dollars a year
and not teaching them and and I bring up
that story specifically in the
concussion they did a study with rods
and
um they gave rats ahead and not very
nice but they were doing a study and
they gave one group of rats their normal
healthy diet the other group of rats
their normal healthy diet plus fructose
or fruit sugar
and then they measured them at three
weeks
at three weeks the rats with the healthy
diet without the sugar could run mazes
they already knew so their brains were
healing the rats who got
their healthy diet plus fructose were
still confused
that Sugar
decreases healing because it's
pro-inflammatory
um and it disrupts brain function
so why is Gatorade on the sidelines
right in a brain damaging sport it's
it's it's just nuts
from a neuroscience perspective I mean
you know I mean they could have
electrolyte
powders that don't have added red dye
sodium just yeah yeah some kind of
sodium supplement that will help you
retain water and stay hydrated so
um so what is the right diet then I mean
this is always such a Hot Topic anyone
listening is probably interested in
health and wellness and I feel like Diet
is one of those things that comes and
goes and waves and Ebbs and flows and
new stuff emerges and something that was
great is horrible and the next thing
comes along so what is the like what is
the most healthy diet for your brain
so I I think really all effective
long-term diets say the same things
that high quality calvaries and calories
matter
um but the quality actually matters more
in a society where 72 percent of us are
overweight we're consuming like for
example
Americans are drinking nearly 500
calories a day where in 1982 that number
was 225 calories a day that extra 275
calories
puts 25 pounds of fat a year on your
body so stop drinking your calories is
what I would say
um
water is really important I don't think
anybody says that's not a good thing
your brain is 80
water so your body is 70 water so being
dehydrated by just two percent decreases
your spatial awareness so for race car
drivers absolutely critical to be
hydrated
[Music]